[موسيقى]
انها ثمنه بتوقيت جرينتش الحادي عشر
بتوقيت الرياضه نص وهيبشراير وهذه اخبار
الساعه
بين روسيا واوكرانيا سباق تجهيش وتسلح
يعكس حربا طويله الامد والنيتو يراقب
نشاطا موسكو من رومانيا
اوروبا
طالبان تستخدم حيله شد الحبل مع المراه
تخفف قيدا وتفرض اخر والحركه تنتزع
اعترافا من نوع خاص
الركود العالمي يفرض نفسه في منتدى غابوث
توقعات متشائمه وتحذيرات من ازمه خطيره
هذا العام
[موسيقى]
وسعهم اوقاتنا اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه
تصاعدوا حده الحرب في اوكرانيا لا يزيدك
الا اسرارا على تقويه جيشيهما سواء
بالعداد او بالافراد ليعطيه مؤشرا واضحا
على حرب طويله الامل فاذا كانت اوكرانيا
تلحها على حلفائها الغربيين بامدادها
بالاسلحه فان روسيا تسارع الخطا لتعزيز
صفوف جيشها وزير الدفاع الروسي سريع شيكو
واعلن رفعت اعداد القوات المسلحه الروسيه
ليصل الى مليون ونصف المليون جندي في
الفتره ما بين 2023
و2020
خلال السنوات الثلاثه المقبله
منذ بدايه العمليه العسكريه الروسيه في
الاراضي الاوكرانيه ظلت موسكو تعمل على
تعزيز صفوف قواتها بعناصر اضافيه ودعم
الجيش الروسي
بصفوفه ضم اليه افراد من المجموعه فاكنار
الخاصه فضلا عن مقاتلين من الشيشان دون ان
ننسى المجندين الذين تم ضمهم خلال عمليه
التجنيد الواسعه التي اطلقت في وقت سابق
[موسيقى]
علي الطرف الاخر والحديث هنا عن الجانب
الاوكراني تراهنك
من اجل مواجهه القوات الروسيه ومواصله
حملتها في استرجاع الاراضي التي سيطرت
عليها موسكو اوكرانيا
اخرها دبابات ومدرعات في انتظار تلق
المسيح
سيده الميدان ربما صاحبه القتال البري
تورت عن الحروب الحديثه مؤخرا لتعود اليوم
بثقالها خطط استراتيجيه اوكرانيه باتت
الدبابات لا تغيب عنها استعدادا لشن عمليه
حاسمه او حتى لصد عمليه بريه كبرى قد
تشنها روسيا في الربيع القادم واقع عسكري
جديد يغير اهتمامات اوكرانيا من حرب
السماء الى الارض من الطائرات بدون طيار
والحرب السبرانيه وغيرها مما تعرف من
الاسلحه المتطوره الى البر والدبابات
بعد الحديث عن المرحله الجديده من الصراع
العسكري في الربيع القادم استفاقت
اوكرانيا عما تبقى لها من دبابات قديمه
تحتاج الى الصيانه وصيانتها بيد الروس فقط
ما دفع كياف لتطلق نداءات الى اوروبا
للمساعده
نداءات لبتها اولا فرنسا بتاكيد ارسال
دبابات خفيفه من طراز اي ام اكس 10 فيما
بريطانيا تعاهدت بتزويد اوكرانيا باربعه
عشره دبابه من طراز شالنجر كما ابدت
الولايات المتحده استعدادا بتزويد
اوكرانيا بدبابات او مدرعه
وحدها المانيا لم تتحرك اتجاه تزويد
اوكرانيا بدبابات من طراز لو بارد
الالمانيه المتقدمه كما لم تسمح لاي دوله
اخرى بتقديم هذه الدبابات لاوكرانيا وخاصه
كندا و بولندا قادته الجيش الاوكراني
يضغطون للحصول على 300 دبابه و600 مدرعه
في لقلب الموازين عسكريه خاصه في المناطق
التي ضمتها روسيا لوغانس ودونيتسك
وجابوريجيا تتوفر الاسلحه ربما قريبا لكن
يبقى التحدي في مدى سرعه استعداد الجيش
الاوكراني وتدريبه لاستخدام كل المعدات
العسكريه الجديده
موسكو حذرت من الدعم الغربي الاخير
لاوكرانيا مؤكده ان اثره لن يكون سوا
اطاله امد معاناتك وشعبها في حرب بريه قد
تتسع مستقبلا غيداء سالم العربيه
[موسيقى]
معنى الان مينا ميشوك وهي المستشاره في
البرلمان الاوكرانيه مباشره من العاصمه
كيف معنا في اخبار الساعه من العربيه شكرا
لانضمامك الينا لماذا يزيد حلفاء اوكرانيا
من تسليحهم
لاوكرانيا خاصه بالدبابات
الغربيه
فان
المستشار الامن القومي الاوكراني زاره
بلدان غربيه لطلبي المزيد من الاسلحه
الغربيه ونحن نخشى غزه ثاني من روسيا
بلا روسيا سوف
تنضم الى الحرب ولذلك نحتاج للحصول على
هذه الاسلحه والمعدات في هذا الوقت لان
روسيا لم تعطي اي اشارات على انها سوف
تترجع بل بالعكس فهي عاز على المودي قدم
واربما سوف ترتكب المزيد من الهجمات وهذا
ما يتطلب منا ان نستعد ونتوقع اي هجمات
لذلك نريد المزيد من الاسلحه لكن المشكله
تكمن في ان البلدان الغربيه المختلفه ليست
مستعده
لتزويدنا بهذه الاسلحه نرى بعض تردد من
لدن بعض البلدان الغربيه
وهناك طبعا دبابات
الدول الغربيه يعني هي متردده في تزويدكم
بهذه الاسلحه همم فرنسا مثلا تعاهدت
بتقديم همم مجموعه من الدباباتها كذلك
بريطانيا همم بدباباتها ودبابات ابرامز
همم طلبت كيف المزيد منها من قبل الولايات
المتحده فمن تقصدين انه بعض الدول
المتردده في مدكرانيا بالمزيد من هذه
الاسلحه
اه ضبط مصنع
هناك الكثير من البلدان تقول انها مستعده
لتزويدنا بلسعه لكنها لا تفعل ذلك وهنا
يكمن الفارق الكبير
بالنسبه للاسلحه الامريكيه فنحن لم نحصل
على ما نريده من الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وهذا ينطبق ايضا على المملكه
المتحده فالكثير منها الخبراء العسكريين
يقولون ان هناك مخاوف لان روسيا ربما
ستحصل على التكنولوجيا هذه الدبابات
البريطانيه وغيرها عندما تاتي الى
اوكرانيا
تحدثت في معرض حديثك ان كل هذا الاستعداد
بهذه الدبابات هو تحسب لغزو بري كبير من
قبل روسيا في الفتره المقبله قد تشارك فيه
بلاروسيا كذلك هل نحن همم
لحظه فارقه في هذه الحرب بين روسيا
واوكرانيا امام تحول في مسار هذه الحرب
تعتقدين مقبلون عليه قريبا
سالتك بما ان كل هذه الاستعدادات
بالدبابات خصوصا وتتوقعون غزوا بريه من
قبل روسيا قد تشارك فيه بيلاروسيا كذلك هل
هذه لحظه تحول في مسار الحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه
طبعا هذا الكلام صحيح
اي تغيرت جذريه طبعا لا يمكن لي ان يتوقع
نتائج هذه الحرب ولكن الديناميكيه سوف
تتغير بالتاكيد في مجريات هذه الحرب ومن
اجل ذلك فنحن نستعد لاي احتمالات
جزء من الاستعدادات في ظل التعاون بين
روسيا وبيلاروسيا
معي سنتحدث عن دعم غربي اخر لاوكران هذه
المره هو دعم مالي واعد لمناقشه الموضوع
اذا مشاهدينا اوكرانيا ستتلقى اكبر مساعده
ماليه اوربيه اعلنت عنها رئيسه المفوضيه
الاوروبيه ارسل لافندر لاين في ذا فويس في
اطار الدعم المستمر لاوكرانيا نستمع
بالنولوجيا
اوكرانيا وتقدم المساعدات لاستعاده الطاقه
والتدفئه والمياه بالاضافه الى التحضير
لجهود اعاده الاعمار على المدى الطويل
المفوضيه ستقدم ثلاثه مليارات يورو كدفعه
اولى من حزمه الدعم المليء الذي تبلغ
قيمته 18 مليارا للعام الحالي وهي اكبر
مساعده ماليه على الاطلاق لدوله ثالثه
من اوكرانيا على كيف توزع اوكرانيا هذا
الدعم الذي تتحدث عنه ارسل لاين ثمانيه
عشر مليون يورو مليار يورو اذا ولكن فقد
الاتصال مع شكر لها اذا ميلا من شك
المستشاره في البرلمان
وعلى وقع هذا التصعيد الاذان في اوكرانيا
وفي خطوه لمراقبه النشاط الروسي ارسل لاحف
شمال الاطلسي الاولى طائرات المراقبه الى
قاعده جويه بالقرب من العاصمه الرومانيه
لمراقبه النشاط العسكريه داخل اراضي تحالف
العسكري كما انه من المتوقع ايضا ان تصل
طائره مراقبه اخرى ريان الى العاصمه
الرومانيه لتقوم بمهامها خلال الاسابيع
المقبله
[موسيقى]
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه في افغانستان
وبامر من طالبان مجسمات وعرض الازياء اما
مغطات او مقطوعه الراس
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد في كلمه له في مؤتمر
تحدث وزير الخارجيه السعوديه فيصل بن
فرحان عن استقرار
وحول المباحثات مع ايران اشار وزير
الخارجيه السعوديه ان الرياض تواصلت مع
ايران لمحاوله البحث عن طريق للحوار
مع جيراننا لان المؤمن
الخلافه تشعر بقوه بان ما قمنا به في
المملكه وما يقوم به اخرون في المنطقه
خاصه دول مجلس التعاون الخليجي لمعالجه
التحدياتهم والاستثمار في دولتهم
السياسيه كانت علامه قويه للايران واخرين
في المنطقه بانه هناك مسار بعيدا عن
الجدالات والنزاعات القديمه تجاه الازدهار
مشترك كل ما تمكنا من التعاون في المنطقه
كل ما عملنا معا وحققنا الازدهار ليس فقط
لشعبنا بل لمنطقتنا وخارجي
[موسيقى]
الشعبيه المتواصله رغم حملته قمع النظام
تشهد ايران موجه جديده من الاضرابات هذه
المره في قطاع النفط والغاز تجمعات
الاحتجاجيه انطلقت في عده مدن ايرانيه
لموظفي شركه النفط الايرانيه احتجاجا على
الاوضاع المعاشيه وفدا للروعه
السلام عليكم
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
في شارع السارموه يخنا زمان
حمله
السلطات الامنيه والمانيه بتهمه التقاط
صور لمراكز النفط الحساسه في محافظه
كوجستان جنوب البلاد وذكرت وسائل الاعلام
ايرانيه ان عمليه الاعتقال هذه تمت خلال
التقاط المصور الالماني صورا لحقل
الراجاري النفطي في محافظه خوزستان ويوصل
النظام تضييق الخناقه على حريه الصحه
واعتقال الصحفيين
بحجه التجسس وتدخل دول الغربيه في الشهور
الداخليه
في المقابل وجهه رئيسه المفوضيه الاوروبيه
ارسل بندر لاين رساله شديده اللهجه للنظام
الايراني بسبب القمع والاعدامات وقالت في
منتدى دابوس انها تؤيد بشده توسيع
العقوبات ضد النظام وادراج الحرس الثوري
الايراني على قائمه المنظمات الارهابيه
وهم يدرسون على حقوق الانسان الاساسيه
باقدامهم لذا فانما نراه امر لا يصدق وما
يحدث في ايران يحتاج الى رساله قويه جدا
ورد فعل قوي جدا بالتالي فاننا نتطلع
بالفعل الى جوله جديده من العقوبات وساؤيد
ايضا ادراج الحرس الثوري في القائمه لقد
سمعت عده وزراء يطلبون ذلك واعتقد انه على
حق
الاشاره
في طهران يفضل ان تتم مهاجمه المرشد عوضا
عن مهاجمه الرئيس كي لا تضطر الحكومه
لتقديم تنازل وقالت الصحيفه ان ابراهيم
رئيسي يتجنب النوم لان القوى المؤيده
للديمقراطيه في ايران توجه الغضبان الى
مكان اخر
صبا المتظاهرون في ايران ومعهم بعض
الاصلاحين غضبهم على المرشد منذ دلاع
الاحتجاجات في الشارع الايراني
لكنهم تجنبوا الرئيس الايراني استثناء
رئيسي لم يغضب النظام بل على العكس من ذلك
بحسب صحيفه فينانز والابتعاد عن مهاجمه
رئيسي يعني عدم مهاجمه الحكومه وبالتالي
فهي لن تكون مضطره الى تقديم تنازلات بحسب
الصحيفه التي رات ان ابتعاد الرئيس
الايراني عن الواجهه يناسب القياده
الايرانيه حتى وان صبغ غضب المحتجين على
خامسه
كيهان التابعه لمرشد ايران اقرت بسخط
المتظاهرين على خامنه مشيره الى ان
المحتاجين لم يهتفوا بشعارات ضد اي سياسي
اخر
اقرار فسره البعض لانه محاوله من خامنئي
للافاده من ذلك في تقويه سلطته من خلال
اقناع السياسيين بانه راس الحربه في
الدفاع عن النظام
ومع اتساع غضب الشارع الايراني على النظام
ورموزه يوما بعد يوم يحاول النظام بكل
الطرق ايجاد مخرج باستخدام القوه او
بغيرها لايقاف مد هذه التظاهرات المستمر
معنا من امستردام الايرانيه يعقوب سعيد
يعقوب اهلا بك معنا في اخبار الساعه لماذا
يهتف المحتاجون في ايران ضد المرشد علي
خامنئي ويستثنون الرئيس ابراهيم رئيسي
هي طيبه لك استاذ صهيب وكذلك المشاهدين
قناه العربيه بكل تاكيد اذا ما نظرنا الى
الدستور الايراني الى القوانين الداخليه
في ايران نرى بان المرشد هو الحاكم الفعلي
في ايران يعني خاصه بان الحكومه في ايران
دائما ما كانت توجه لها او حتى المرشد
نفسه كان دائما ان يتم يحاول ان يتملص من
مسؤوليته اتجاه
تقديم التنازلات الحقيقيه للمطالب الشعبيه
من خلال توجيه ال- ال- التهم الى الحكومه
بالتقصير وذلك حصل لا في حكومه خاتمي ومن
بعدها يعني احمد نجاه وكذلك روحاني اما
اتصور بين المحتاجين فهموا هذه اللعبه وهم
تماما بان المرشد
وصلاحياته لا متناهيه في البلاد هي
المشكله الاساسيه التي يواجهونها وليس
الحكومات التي تاتي وتتغير بعد كل اربع
سنوات
بالتاكيد عندما ننظر الى مستوى
الصلاحيات التي يتمتع بها المرشد الايراني
من من الناحيه الداخليه نرى بانه هؤلاء
المحت
جين التهم الى يعني الى المرشد نفسه بدل
الشخصيات
طيب يعقوب الان يعني بعد كل هذه المده
المظاهرات التي انطلقت في سبتمبر 2022 بعد
مقتل امين على يد شرطه الاخلاق الى اليوم
في هذه المرحله الان همم ماذا نعرف عن حجم
التضاهرات والزخمها مع طبعا همم حمله
القمع الشديده مع الاعدامات المتكرره الى
اين وصل زخم الاحتجاجات الان
طيب يعقوب يبدو اننا فقدنا الاتصال معه في
امستردام شكرا جزيلا لك ولكن نذهب الان
مباشره الى نيويورك وهذه الكلمه للممثل
الدائم الاتحاد الروسي باسيليني فنسيا في
الامم المتحده ومعتقدات سياسيه دينيه نوع
الاجتماعي
الثروه مكان الاقامه اللغه او على اي اساس
اخر بحسب الماده الرابعه والعشرين ان
المواطنين الذين ينتمون الى الاقليات بحسب
القانون يحق لهم ان يدرسوا بلغتهم الام او
ان يدرسوا اللغه الام
في
المؤسسات الخاصه او الحكوميه بحسب الماده
الثالثه والخمسين نتدابير نظام كياف تطيع
عارض مع التزامات اوكرانيا لحمايه حقوق
كافه الاقليات وذلك بحسب الوثائق الدوليه
ان تمييز ضد الاقليات الوطنيه
ومنع الحق في التعليم
واظهار الثقافه والدراسه باللغه الام هذه
كلها تظهر في الاتفاقيات الدوليه
ومنها العهد الدولي لحقوق المدنيه
والسياسيه
وتفاقيات يونسكو ضد التمييز في التعليم
1960 اتفاقيه حقوق الطفل
1989 والبرتقال الاول الاتحاد الاوروبي
حول حمايه حقوق الانسان
والاتفاقيه المتصله بحمايه الاقليات
المندوب الروسي في الامم المتحده برازيلي
[موسيقى]
بالعوده الى ايران اكدت طهران دعمها لمسار
التطبيعه بين دمشق وانقى خلال زياره وزير
الخارجيه الايرانيه حسين امير عبد الله
يعني الى تركيا
الى الدخول على خط الوساطه بين تركيا
والنظام السوري فيما يرى اخرون ان
الايراني
على وقع الخطوات التركيه نحو التطبيع مع
دمشق وصل وزير الخارجيه الايراني حسين
امير عبد اللهيان الى انقره للبحث عن موطئ
قدم لبلاده في مسار التطبيع الجديد
التصريحات الرسميه بين مسؤولي البلدين لم
تخرج عن مالوف الدبلوماسيه من ترحيب
بالجهود الساعيه لتقريب وجهات النظر بين
تركيا والنظام السوري
اكد على هذا الموقف ولتحقق هذه الخطوط
نتائج واضحه سنكون على تواصل مع ايران
بشكل العلاقات بين الدولتين نحن ممتنون
جدا من وصول العلاقات الى هذا المستوى
ندعم ونؤمن باي خطوه ايجابيه بين الدولتين
خفايا الاجتماعات وفقه ما نقلت مصادر من
انقره ابرزت رغبه ايرانيه في دور المحوريه
بالوساطه بين الاتراك ونظام الاسد موازن
للدوري الروسي وذلك قبل توجه وزير
الخارجيه التركي الى واشنطن لنقل هذا
الملف الى طاوله المسؤولين الامريكيين
الرافدين للتقارب مع الاسد لكن دوره طهران
المنشود يراه اخرون انه بعيد المنال حاليا
امام وساطه روسيه قويه نجحت في عقد لقاء
ثلاثي على مستوى وزراء الدفاع
ان تكون بابا للحوار التركي السوري ولكن
هناك دور روسي ابراس وهناك وساطه روسيه
همم
تحقيق هذا الاجتماع الوزاري بالبساطه
الروسيه وفي موسكو ويسود اعتقاده الاوساط
السياسيه التركيه
ان طهران لعبت دورا في تاخير اجتماع وزراء
خارجيه تركيا وروسيا وسوريا حيث كان من
المنتظر ان يعقد في النصف الثاني من يناير
الجاري لكن الاجتماع تاجل ولم تسرع عجله
التطبيع وفق الاهواء التركيه يرى متابعون
لمسار التطبيعي مع دمشق ان انقره ستحاول
على الاقل خلال الفتره الحاليه تجنب
الاستعانه بواسطه جديد طالما ان الوساطه
الروسيه ما زالت تؤتي ثمارها وتقبل تركيا
لدور ايراني لن يكون الا في حال تعثرت
موسكو بالوصول الى اختراقات تمنح انقره
مكاسب سريعه قبل الانتخابات زيدان زينجو
العربيه اسطنبول
[موسيقى]
الى افغانستان الان عوده نسائيه افغانستان
لمزاوله العمل في مجال الصحه في المنظمات
الانسانيه منح بارقه امل باستعاده المراه
لجزء من حقوقها المسلوبه في افغانستان لكن
الطالبه وضعت ضوابط حتى في منح هذه
الموافقه فاعتبر اولا انها موافقه مؤقتا
وحذرت ايضا من ان اعمال المراه ستكون
محدوده وهو ما يزيد من حاله الاحباط التي
تعيشها النساء بعد سلبهن حقهن في التعليم
الجامعي والعمل وقبلها حقهن في التنزه
وارتياد المكتبات والنوادي الرياضيه لكن
عوده نشاط بعض المنظمات حتى وان كان
محدودا سيخفف من الازمه الانسانيه التي
تفاقمت بعد قرار تعليق المنظمات غير
الحكوميه لعملياتها احتجاجا على حظر
طالبان عمل النسائي فيها بحسب مسؤولين
وتعمل حوالي
1260 منظمه غير حكوميه في البلاد وفقه
وزاره الاقتصاد وتوظف الاف النساء في
مناصب اساسيه سواء في برامج المعونه
الغذائيه او في مجالات الصحه والتعليم
وتقدم المنظمات غير الحكوميه مساعدات
الاساسيه في افغانستان والتي يعاني اكثر
من نصف سكانها من انعدام الامن الغذائي
الحال
[موسيقى]
طالبان خففت قيد من القيود وفرضت اخر ضمن
موجه التضييق التي تفرضها على المراه في
مختلف نواحي الحياه بلغ الامر بالحركه هذه
المره اجباره تجار المحلات على تغطيه رؤوس
مجسمات عارضات الازياء الاصطناعيه او
قطعها نهائيا عبد الله نادر
هكذا تبدو محلات بيع الملابس النسويه في
العاصمه كابول وبقيه المدن الافغانيه
مجسمات عارضات ازياء اما مقطوعه الراس او
مغطاه ببلاستيك او خرقه قماش قماشيا مع
قوانين طالبان الصارمه جميله
مسيح الله احد اصحاب محل بيع ملابس النساء
في كابول يقول انه خضع لاوامر طالبان
بتغطيه رؤوس مجسمات العرضات او قطعها وان
مسؤولي وزاره الامر بالمعروف والنهي عن
المنكر يراقبون السوق ويتفحصون هذه الدمى
بين الحين والاخر
الامر على الرغم من اثاره السلبيه
وامام هذا التطور اللاسلكي لتعليمات
طالبان يشتكي اصحاب المتاجر الافغان من
تكبد خسائر ماليه كبيره
في مجسمات عارضات الازياء التي تكلف
الواحده منها بين 70 و80 دولارا في وقت
يشهد اقتصاد البلاد ركودا يضعه على وشك
الانهيار تماثيل
عرضه لتعتبرها طالبان اصناما تعيد الناس
لعصور ما قبل الاسلام وينبغي حظرها امر
يرفضه اصحاب المتاجر وباعت الملابس الذين
يخشون ان يؤدي هذا الى غياب الزبائن
وبالتالي اختفاء ما تبقى من دخلهم عبد
الاله نادر العربيه كابول
[موسيقى]
رغم الجدري الكبير الذي اثارته قرارات
طالبان الاخيره في حق المراه الا ان
الحركه نجحت في الحصول على اعتراف من نوع
خاص الاعتراف لم يكن دوليه بل الكترونيا
بحديث هنا عن العلامه الزرقاء تويتر حيث
بدا بعض اعضاء حركه طالبان في استخدام هذه
العلامات على منصه التواصل الاجتماعي
تويتر مستفيدين من ميزه شراء العلامه
الزرقاء التي اتاحها الملك الجديد الى مصر
وكان هدايه الله هدايه وزير الوصول الى
المعلومات في طالبان قد حصل على العلامه
الزرقاء قبل ان يتم حذفها كما ان المسؤول
العسكري في الحركات مبين خان حصل هو الاخر
على اشاره التحقق الزرقاء من تويتر
[موسيقى]
بينما لم تبدا بعد عاصفه ملفات السريه لا
يزال الرجل وفريقه مصممنا على التزام
الصمت
تناسلت معه اسئله عديده ابرزها ماذا نجح
الرئيس الامريكي ومستشاريه في التعاطي مع
هذه القضيه شبكه سي ان ان اكدت ان الرئيس
يشعر بالاحباط من الطريقه التي تسير عليها
الامور في ظل التوجه نحو عدم الادلاء باي
صوت بخصوص القضيه وقرر بوب باور المحامي
الشخصي للرئيس الامريكي والمكلف بالقضيه
ان الكشف العلاني عن تفاصيل القضيه يمكن
ان يؤثر على التحقيقات الجاريه هذا وتمسكت
الدائره الصغيره من المستشارين البيت
الابيض وبيض المرسه عن كتب بهذه التوجيهات
معتقدين ان الافصاح عن المزيد من
المعلومات قد يضر بالتحقيق
بعض حلفاء بيدن بدورهم لم يستسيغوا
الطريقه التي تعامل بها بيت الابيض مع
موضوع الملفات السريه حيث قال السمكه
الديمقراطيه السابقه دودج جونز وهو حليف
مقرب من بايرن ان البيت الابيض ارتكب
اخطاء غير مقصوده حين تاخر في الاعلان عن
اكتشاف الوفاء هذا في الوقت الذي قالت فيه
السيناتور الديمقراطيه
باستبينو انك اكتشاف الوثائق السريه كان
محرجا بالتاكيد الرئيس
[موسيقى]
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه مساعده الطيار
للرحله الايطاليه المنكوبه تلتحق بزوجها
الذي توفي في حادثه مشابهه قبل 16 عاما
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد توقعاته باحتمال حدوث
ركود في الاقتصاد العالمي تتوالى
والمؤشرات ما فاته تتواجد من مؤسسات
مختلفه معطيات جعلت شبح الركود العنوان
الرئيسي لمنتدى الاقتصاد العالمي في دابوس
بسويسرا
على التحضيرات من الازمه بحسب وكاله
المختصه في الشؤون الاقتصاديه في دبليو سي
اجره استطلاعا للراي جاءت نتائجها سابقا
من بين اكثر من 4000 و 400 من قاده
الاعمال الذين تم استطلاعه ارائهم توقع
على ثلاثه وسبعون بالمئه اي ينخفض النمو
العالمي خلال العام الحالي و فضلا عن ملف
الركود الاقتصاديه فان ملتقى دهبوس لهذه
السنه يحمل اهميه خاصه ايضا لانقاذه لاول
مره منذ يناير 2020 بعد توقفه بسبب رائحه
رونالدو كما ان الازمه الاقتصاديه
العالميه التي تسببت فيها الحرب في
اوكرانيا
تجعلنا مسلطه
وما سيحمله من خلاصه
اثار الركود بدات تظهر جليا جليه في ثاني
اقوى اقتصادي في العالم والحديث هنا طبعا
عن الاقتصاد الصيني فالنمو الاقتصادي في
الصين سجل العام الماضي ثاني ادنى مستوى
له منذ اربعه عقود وذلك بعد تاكله بشكل
كبير بالاجراءات المتخذه لمكافحه جائحه
كورونا ثاني اكبر اقتصاد في العالم انما
بنسبه ثلاثه بالمئه فقط في 2022 اي اقل من
نصف معدل للعامل الذي سابقه والبالغ حوالي
ثمانيه في المئه
هموم اقتصادي المتواضع اذا سجلته الصين
خلال العام المنصرم ما دفعها الى تعليق
السياسه صفر كوبد لانعاش اقتصادها رغم ما
تلاه من ارتفاع في حاله الاصابات واللحظه
في عاشت في الانفاق الاستهلاكيه خلال
الاسابيع الماضيه لكنه ضل ضعيفا ويتوقع
صندوق النقد الدولي اللا يزيد النمو
الاقتصادي الصيني عن اربعه خلال الفتره
المتبقيه من العقد الحالي لكن الاراء
القادمه من الصين تتوقع عكس ذلك حيث تتنبا
يتنبا اقتصاديون صينيون ان ينمو الاقتصاد
بنسبه خمسه في المئه خلال العام
يتم تقييم النمو الاقتصادي انطلاقا من
الربع الثاني من العام وسوف نشهد انتعاشه
قويه حاليا لدينا توقعات بنمو اجمالي
للناتج المحلي للعام عند 5% ومع ذلك بنسبه
للربع الاول مازلنا نعتبره فتره انتقاليه
وعرى حيث قد نشهد بالفعل انكماشا بدلا من
النمو
الدكتور دانيال اهلا بك معنا في اخبار
الساعه هل هذا الضعف في نمو الاقتصاد
الصيني يجعل من الركود العالمي حتميه في
تحيه لك يا سيدي ولا مشاهدين الكرام اليوم
نعم ضعف الاقتصاد الصيني واصبح واضح
المعالم هناك ضعف الطالب الداخلي هناك
ازمه في السوق العقاري هناك الكثير من
الازمات هناك انحدار في النمو الديموغرافي
وكل هذا عوامل لن تساعد على تحقيق نمو في
الصين على ما كان عليه فصل في السابق
وبالتالي حتى الوصول الى 5% انا استبعد
هناك كثير من التوقعات هنا ان يكون في
حدود
4% على على احسن تطبيق وبالتالي 5% هو
صعبه المنال كما كان في التقرير السابق
ولكن بالعوده الى سؤالك يا سيدي هل نعم
بالتاكيد ان عمليا ان الصين سوف تؤثر بشكل
كبير على نمو التجاره العالميه وبالتالي
على النمو على الاقتصاد العالمي اليوم الى
اليوم هي تؤثر بنسبه نصف نقطه مئويه بحجم
التجاره العالميه وهذا طبيعي ان يؤدي الى
المساهمه اكثر في اكثر في انخفاض الانشطه
الاقتصاديه العالميه وخاصه في النصف الاول
لذلك من المتوقع ان يكون هناك نوع من
الركود الطفيف خلال الفصل الاول من
ولكن اليوم المعطيات سيدي يوسف في
الولايات المتحده او في في اوروبا لن تشير
الى الان ان يكون هناك همم ركود مؤكد فيها
يعني ركوب طفيف بمعنى لا نتحدث عن شيء
يشبه همم الازمه الاقتصاديه العالميه في
الى اليوم اعود واكرر الى اليوم سيدي على
الرغم من ان هناك تباط كبير في الانشطه
الاقتصاديه ولكن لا تزال الولايات المتحده
واوروبا تبرزان مقاومه كبيره هناك بعض
المؤشرات تبرز ان هناك مقاومه كبيره فيها
ثاني اقتصاديتين اليوم ننظر الى اوروبا ان
هناك
حتى نموره هي الذي غالبا ما تكون نظرته
سلبيه الى الاتصال خفض عمليا نظرته
لاوروبا من
عفوا ناقص 0.7 ركود خلال الفصل الاول الى
0.1% وبالتالي عمليا اغلب هذه البنوك بدات
تغيير نظرتها للاتحاد الاوروبي نظرا
للمؤشرات الصناعيه للحدث الاخيره وبالتالي
نعم سوف يكون هناك طفيف خلال الفصل الاول
لا يشبه ما حدث في 2008 الى اليوم طيب همم
ولكن ذلك يعني همم التقارير المتشائمه
خاصه اليوم يعني
يبحث على القلق بالنسبه للدول العربيه يا
دكتور دانيال كيف ترى وضعها مع هذه
التوقعات المتشائمه وما هي الدول العربيه
التي تعتقد ان هي الاكثر هشاشه او الاكثر
تاثرا بهذا الركود وان كان طفيفا كما توقت
نعم هناك 30
عناصر في سؤالك يا سيدي اليوم العنصر
الاول ال- ال- المخاوف العالميه في مؤتمر
دوسا لا تتعلق في الركود الحالي المخاوف
هي عمليان هي تقسيم النظام العالمي الى
الثلاثي بلوكات جيو اقتصاديه الا هي الصين
للولايات المتحده اوروبا وبدات الحساسات
الحمائيه في هذا الدول ماذا يعني عمليا
شرد ما اكثر فاكثر في الاقتصاد العالمي
شارما اكثر في نمو التجاره العالميه اشهر
عندما اكثر في عمليه تبادل اليد العامله
وفي الاستثمار وهذا نوعا المخيف لانه يعمل
عمليا يؤدي الى توزيع غير عادل للمخاطر
وبالتالي سوف يزيل الضغط اكثر على الدول
الناميه وسوف يؤدي فيما لو حصلت عمليه
الركود او اي ازمه اقتصاديه مخاطر اكبر
على هذه الدول اما على الصعيد الدول
العربيه هناك قسمين من هذا الدول هناك دول
تعاني اليوم وللاسف هناك دول كم مصر لبنان
سوريا حتى العراق وغيرها من الدول هي
عمليه هي في عين الازمه اليوم نتيجه ازمه
الديون التي تعاني منها هذه الدول اما في
باقه الدول الاخرى صندوق الخليج دورا
النفطي عمليا هي التي تملك اليوم كميات
كبيره من السيوله تملك قدره شرائيه هذا
عمليا يدفعها الى تخطي هذه الازمه لانها
لديها عملين امكانيات التحفيز في ما لا
دخل الا الاقتصاد العالمي عمليا في ركود
شكرا جزيلا لك دكتور دانيال ملحم انت
الباحث الاقتصادي كنت معنا من باريس
[موسيقى]
هنا توفيت مساعده طيار الرحله المنكوبه
التي تحطمت في نيبال الاحد الماضي
لتلحق بزوجها الذي توفي في حادث تحطم
طائره المشابه قبل 16 عاما وكانت انجودا
تشاركوا في قياده الطائره التي سقطت
بالقرب من مدينه اخرى ما اصفره عن مقتل
جميع من كانوا على مكه في اسوا كارثه جويه
تشهدها البلاد منذ 30 عاما لكن المفارقه
هي ان زوجها الراحل كان يشارك ايضا في
قياده رحله تابعه لنفس الخطوط الجويه
وكانت وفاته هي التي دفعتها للعمل في مجال
الطيران
ختام اخبار الساعه لهذه الليله تفكيرهم
بابرزها
بين روسيا واوكرانيا سباق تشييش وتسلح
يعكس حربا طويله الامد ونيته يراقب نشاطا
موسكو من رومانيا
اوروبا تدفع باتجاه التصعيد ضد ايران
والحرس الثوري والنظام يجد مخرجا جديدا
لوقف مد الاحتجاجات
طالبان تستخدم حين تشد الحبل مع المراه
تخفف قيدا وتفرد اخر والحركه تنتزع
اعترافا من نوع خاص
الركود العلمي يفرض نفسه في منتدى دابوس
توقعات المتشائمه وتحذيرات من ازمه خطيره
هذا العالم
شكرا لكم على اكرام المشاهده المزيد دائما
على العربيه دوت نت وعلى صفحتنا على مواقع
التواصل الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]